اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه هي ملفات
عندما انطلق برنامج مستقبل الطاقه قبل اقل
من عشر سنوات كان النقاش حول تحول الطاقه
محصورا بالنخبه ولا يثير اهتمام كثير من
الناس الحديث عن تحول الطاقه يصبح طرفا في
دول لا تصل اليها الكهرباء اصلا اليوم
تغير الوضع تماما هناك جندات دوليه متعدده
تحاول تحديد مستقبل الطاقه هناك من يريد
ان يجعل صناعه النفط والغاز من الماضي تحت
شعار مكافحه التغيير المناخي وهناك من
يريد ان يجعلها جزءا من مستقبل الطاقه لكن
بشروط بيئيه وتكنولوجيه مختلفه الصين لن
تتوقف عن حرق الوقود الاحفوري الى ان تصبح
متاكده من جهزيه منظومه الطاقات النظيفه
بالطبع فان النقاش حول معادله امن المناخ
من ناحيه وامن الطاقه وكلتها من ناحيه
اخرى ليس نقاشا تقنيها بحثا بل يقع في قلب
الصراعات الج سياسيه عن السحب من
المخزونات النفطيه الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
بمقدار 15 مليون برميل منطقه تونه بالذات
من اكثر مناطق العالم تاثرا بهذا التحول
ولذلك لابد ان نكون في قلب النقاش العالمي
حول مستقبل الطاقه فسواء قرارات اوبيك
كلاس خفض الانتاج ام اجل هذه الخطوه فان
اجتماعها سيوفر عنصر وضوح في فتره يشتد
فيها الغمر برنامجنا هو هذه المنصه
الاعلاميه التي اعتقد انها ضروريه جدا
لمتابعه هذا المعترف الكبير الذي يعيد رسم
مستقبل الاقتصادات منطقتنا ويؤثر على كل
شيء في حياتنا بدءا من النمو الاقتصادي
ومستويات التضخم مرورا بجوده الحياه
ووصولا الى نوع السياره التي سنقوتها
جائزه افضل برنامج اقتصادي من منتدى
الاعلام العربي التي فاز بها البرنامج
مؤخرا اعتبرها اعترافا وتقديرا لدخولنا
المبكر في قلب هذا النقاش لنضع المشاهد
العربي في اجواء هذا التحول الكبير من
حولنا الشمس لا تشرق دائما والرياح لا تهب
دوما مستقبل الطاقه يتشكل اليوم
[موسيقى]